con su sorpresivo viaje a moscú el
primer ministro israelí naftalí bennett
da un paso más en su intento de mediar
entre rusia y ucrania este traslado
inusual para un premier judío ortodoxo
en el descanso del shabat ocurre luego
de dos rondas de llamadas telefónicas
con los mandatarios de ambos países y
después de que volodymyr selenski
propusiera abiertamente a israel como un
mediador se ignora si frenar este
conflicto estuvo en esa agenda de esta
reunión de tres horas entre benet y el
presidente vladimir putin sólo se supo
que abordaron la invasión a ucrania y el
acuerdo nuclear con irán y que vedette e
informó de estos detalles a sus pares de
ucrania francia y alemania- según la
prensa israelí y bennett también
advirtió de ese viaje a eeuu que tiene
muy pocas expectativas y ve con recelo
esa neutralidad israelí frente a esta
guerra y es que el estado tiene una
relación histórica con ambos por ejemplo
más de un millón de rusos migraron hasta
aquí tras la caída de la unión soviética
pero israel se ha negado a mandar equipo
militar a ucrania y se ha movido en una
ambigüedad sobre rusia a quien necesita
para atacar objetivos pro iraníes en
siria
esta ambivalencia la válido críticas de
parte de la opinión pública que se
identifica con los ucranianos y respeta
selenski por sus orígenes judíos no
obstante israel ha enviado ayuda
humanitaria a ucrania y ha reforzado las
redes para repatriar a israelíes y
recibir a judíos ucranianos mediante la
aliá o inmigración judía desde el inicio
del conflicto más de 2000 ucranianos han
llegado a israel